gigantes de aluminio en el corazón del
campo cantábrico aquí y césar vea pensó
que estaba alcanzando en sueño producir
electricidad limpia y obtener una
entrada de dinero de por vida esto que
veis aquí
es mi parque solar
y lo que iba a ser una
fuente de energía fue la fuente de
pesadillas en 2007 césar invirtió un
millón de euros en estos seis paneles
solares en aquel momento el gobierno
socialista animaba a los ciudadanos a
invertir en la energía fotovoltaica les
prometían proporcionarles una ayuda para
la inversión y les garantizaban un
precio de compra fijo por la energía
producida tardábamos en recuperarla como
15 años y a partir de ahí eran
beneficios pues dije bueno mi hijo sisí
tiene que marcharse fuera a este país a
estudiar que ojalá lo haga tendrá un
dinero para poder vivir para poder
estudiar pero tres años después el
panorama se tornó oscuro los
inversionistas atraídos por la alta
insolación de españa acudieron en masa
al país como resultado la capacidad de
producción de electricidad fue nueve
veces mayor de lo previsto al no poder
pagar el estado recortó las ayudas
prometidas nos llega una comunicación
del gobierno
diciendo los que nos van a dejar de
pagar que nos han expulsado del sistema
de primas no te imaginas
que tu presidente de tu país mira este
proyecto fue el sueño de toda una
familia
nuestra foto
del padre
sin montadas
juntos invirtieron todos sus ahorros con
la disminución de las ayudas era
imposible pagar su préstamo cuerpo cómo
pierden su casa familiar de repente ver
que puedes perder algo que viene de años
atrás de la familia pues es duro
sobre la parte económica es importante
pero la humillación personal es lo peor
o sea que te traten como como un
delincuente que es como nos han tratado
eso es lo peor esto te hace perder la
salud para encontrar una salida césar
acude diariamente al congreso de los
diputados en madrid desde hace seis
meses desde las 8 de la mañana hasta las
2 de la tarde
permanece de pie para exigir justicia
y aquí me sacan con una solución o por
una ambulancia no me voy a mover de aquí
no tengo nada peor y nada mejor que
hacer hace 2 años césar pensaba que
había logrado su objetivo tras dos
huelgas de hambre y varios plantones el
gobierno de pedro sánchez prometió
ayudarle finalmente no pasó nada el psoe
ya ha contestado por una carta escrita
diciéndome que iban a aplicar soluciones
a nuestro caso vial de familias en una
situación como la nuestra era mentira
aunque el caso de césar es uno de los
más graves en españa otras familias
dicen haber sido engañadas 62 mil
familias en total 5.000 de ellas forman
parte de esta asociación
cómo van los contactos del gobierno
bueno un poco fríos
igual que césar estos patriotas pensaron
comprar el sol mientras ayudaban a su
país españa entonces tenía mucha prisa
por cumplir los objetivos de transición
ecológica de la unión europea de todo
esto que han dicho lo único que se ha
cumplido es que nosotros hemos pagado lo
que valía la instalación falta de
previsión malos cálculos estas familias
denuncian la falta de regulación y la
improvisación del estado
[Música]
en madrid ellos como gobierno han dicho
sigan haciendo porque podrían haber
dicho oye quién está y corto aquí ya
está lo que estamos pidiendo es que se
nos compense el daño que nos han
generado es decir que de ese entre 30 y
50 por ciento de recorte que tenemos que
al menos nos compensen con un 20 un 25
por ciento el partido socialista español
no respondió a nuestras preguntas cuando
los contactamos la derecha que también
había recortado las ayudas presenta
ahora una enmienda quizá clave para
estas familias lo que pretende corregir
es qué
y aquellas instalaciones que se hicieron
al amparo de una retribución regulada en
base a una prima la puedan conseguir un
financiamiento que este diputado desea
obtener del futuro fondo nacional para
la sostenibilidad del sistema eléctrico
una nueva forma de financiar las
energías renovables nosotros creemos que
este fondo bueno que tiene que haber una
modificación normativa para que dé
también cabida la retribución del
sistema eléctrico a estos
y productores fotovoltaicos
y siendo muy incierta al igual que su
resultado